Tom Hiddleston opens up about Thor's new
do notice that Thor got a little trim in
the next the next night is so lucky
right and the deadly challenges he faced
making Kong Skull Island
spiders plants that can kill you
[Music]
before we knew Tom Hiddleston as Captain
James Conrad in Kong Skull Island we
knew him as Loki from Thor and the
Avengers this is so unlike you brother
so clandestine notice the throw down a
little trim in the nest the next morning
I did so lucky right I was just gonna
see what I know I pitched for it but it
wasn't gonna fly it Loki as still has
his black long black locks what I love
about it is that there's actually a
reason for that haircut I'm excited for
audiences to find out from superheroes
to super large gorillas it's clear that
British actor has no fear over some of
the biggest challenges that you endured
and in some of these beautiful locations
um I actually love being out in the
location for having the Sun and the wind
and the heat and the bugs and the swamps
was helpful but Australia was hilarious
because I think Australia the Queensland
has the highest concentration of
venomous snakes in the world
spiders plants that can kill you things
designed to keep you out
[Music]
you